[Music]
mounting his key nice tee the
protagonist of Don Quixote charges an
army of giants in his eyes it is his
duty to vanquish these behemoths in the
name of his beloved lady Dulcinea
however this act of valor is
ill-conceived as his squire sancho panza
explains to him time and again this our
enjoins they are merely windmills Don
Quixote is on the church but his
piercing Lance is soon caught in their
sails never discouraged the night stands
proudly and becomes even more convinced
of his mission this sequence encapsulate
much of what is lost about Don Quixote
the epic illogical and soulful tale of
Alonso Quijano who becomes the clumsy
but valiant Don Quixote of La Mancha
known as the knight of the sorrowful
countenance originally published in two
volumes the narrative follows Don
Quixote as he travels through central
and northern Spain fighting the forces
of evil
despite Don Quijote sloth the
imagination his creator Miguel de
Cervantes could never have imagined his
book would become the best-selling novel
of all time
bearing five years as a soldier and five
more enslaved by pirates
Cervantes spent most of his life as a
struggling poet and playwright
it wasn't until his late 50s that he
published his greatest creation
an epic satire of chivalry novels at
this time medieval books chronicling the
adventures of knights and their moral
code dominated European culture while
Cervantes was a fan he was weary of
these repetitive tones which focused
more on listing heroic feats than
character development to challenge them
he wrote Don Quixote the story of a
Hidalgo or idle nobleman who spends his
days and nights reading chivalry novels
driven mad by these stories he fashions
himself a champion for the downtrodden
everyone in his village tries to
convince him to give up his lunacy going
so far as to burn some of the lurid
books in his personal library but Don
Quixote is unstoppable he dresses up in
all shining armor mounts his skinny
horse and leaves his village in search
of glory
Cervantes his novel unfolds as a
collection of episodes detailing the
mishaps of the valiant knight yet unlike
the chivalry books and perhaps all other
prior fiction Cervantes's story deeply
investigates the protagonists inner life
Don Quixote matures as the narrative
develops undergoing and noticeable
transformation this literary revelation
has led many scholars to call Don
Quixote the first mother novel in this
character development doesn't happen in
isolation early on Don Quixote is joined
by a villager turned squire named Sancho
Panza Sancho and Don Quixote are a study
in opposites with one as the grounded
realist to the others idealism they're
lively evolved in friendship is often
credited as the original hero and
psychic duel inspiring centuries of
fictional partnership Don Quijote was a
huge success
numerous editions were published across
Europe in the 17th century even in the
Americas where the church banned all
novels for being sinful distractions
audiences were known to enjoy pirated
editions the book was so well received
that readers clamored for more after a
rival author attempted to cash in when a
fake follow-up Cervantes released the
official sequel in response now
published alongside the first volume as
a completed text this second volume
picks up where the original left off
only now Don Quixote and Sancho have
become folk heroes just as in real life
cervantes included his novel success in
the world of his characters this
unconventional meta awareness created
philosophical complexity as the knight
and his squire ponder the meaning of
their story unfortunately Cervantes had
sold the books publishing rights for
very little
he died rich in fame alone but his
treatise on the power of creativity and
individualism has inspired art
literature popular culture and even
political revolution Don Quixote argues
that our imagination greatly informs our
actions making us capable of change and
indeed making us human how do you
exercise your creativity check out this
playlist for some ideas on how to get
started
[Music]